for the tampa bay rays it's gonna be
right-hander drew rasmussen making his
sixth start on the season you know we
highlighted his last three well that
started out against the boston red sox
up in fenway he went four innies gave up
one hit one earned runs while striking
out four
and that is strike three call
99
three pitches one gone you know when
rasmussen is at his
very best everything looks like it is
full bore powerful and a swing and a
miss speaking of powerful
that's 98 up above the zone
strikeout number two oh and strike three
he drops that slider in there
caught him looking he strikes out the
side this is when you need your ace
right now this is the time tonight no
victories for chris over baltimore texas
and minnesota this is a different animal
yeah this is his first real test
scooped up out there onto first and yes
they turn it red sox do on the second
effort turn two
and get out of the inning no score after
one
full count pitch a slang and a miss 97
four consecutive strikeouts to start
this game bobby d out of the lineup
tonight here's the 2-2
a little flare in the center field
charging onto margot can't make the play
it bounces behind him keeps on rolling
radugo off to the races
luplos scoops it throw into third he's
gonna dive in lose the helmet and he
gets the bag
that'll be a triple yeah marco was in
between he didn't know whether he should
charge this and go for the
shoestring catch dive or whatever he was
just in between and it was out of reach
second triple of the season for verdugo
and here's vasquez looking to pick him
up one out 3-1
that's a shot in the center field down
for a base hit and he misplays this one
run is in to score
vasquez into second
and margot is having a devil of a
timeout there the red sox take advantage
one to nothing that was a ringing line
drive he stung it that ball was stung
and i'll tell you what came off the turf
and just messed him up cross seam
fastball three and one and he stings it
go two
he strikes him out 98 he blew it right
by him
so he went to 98 there to pick up
the second out of the inning and his
fifth strikeout already and here's lopez
his major league debut tonight's 28
years old 5 10 right hand hitter from
puerto rico
a little flare out there to right
fielder rosarina
red sox do get on the board however on
the rbi single by vasquez one nothing
made contact maybe two more four six
got him at first base bang bang
and sale is out of the inning for the
second time he gets a double play
three two a little chopper to first that
will be handled by diaz unassisted three
up three down renfro lost to bad he
broke it on that one nothing boston
that goes flying and he strikes out
he got fooled and just let it go
i thought it was a foul ball per second
but it was the bat it was
bad nelson cruz is bad
no respect for it he just he says i'm
fooled and just let go
yep
so with two outs wander franco screws it
sends a high-fly ball back into right
renfro will go to the wall
good bye
home run for bronco
that's number seven
and the ray's taken two to one lead
wander franco is doing it all for the
raise
his own base streak in 32 consecutive
games
95 miles an hour to put him away strike
three but damage done by franco
gets a two-run homer
lifted into center field
margot is there and he makes the catch
one two three inning
margo's gonna lead off the bottom of the
fourth
2-1 tampa bay
runners taking off
throw down to third and the tag is going
to get him
man they're just getting so aggressive
right there
zunino stayed at first base
and the throw on time oh he's out by a
mile one down two to one tampa bay
in play again going for the tag got the
out and another double play the red sox
have turned three of them in the ball
game
wendell responsible for a couple 2-1
tampa bay
that's a base hit to the left of waltz
and through into right
vasquez has his second hit
this one leads off the fifth that's
gonna be it
four innings plus for rasmussen and a
call to the bullpen fifth man to come to
the plate this matchup lefty on lefty
and a base hit into right rose arena
will make the pickup vasquez heads to
the plate got a chance to get him and he
is
[Applause]
he had no chance
as he pulled out
2-2 martinez to chop to short on the
short hop the pick by bronco out at
second and out at first
6-4-3
franco walls to diaz
to get the inning ending double play one
pitch away from getting out of here here
comes the o2
and a pop-up on a 96 mile an hour
fastball there's schwerberg foul ground
to make the catch
he does get out of it
and strands too
[Applause]
vasquez perfect tonight at the plate two
for two two singles and he's swinging a
high fly ball and left field that's way
back there that ball is out of here
home run christian vasquez he has tied
the game
his sixth of the year what a night for
vaske
three hits on the night and he goes yard
chris sale was coming out again and then
whoops chris you're out of the game
whitlock's coming in so whitlock coming
in not chris sale
ball runner trying to score deborah
slings it home and nice play by vasquez
to dig it and get the tag on him
for out number two the tag he tagged him
on the chest you wonder if his foot was
in
they're not going to challenge not going
to challenge got him nicely done
our goal will be the batter couple of
hits tonight zunino on deck
ground ball they're going to cut him
down again here's the tag and he is out
at home
[Applause]
red sox have done that in back-to-back
innings whitlock he's a magician out
there he gets a weak round ball sends up
the rookie jaren duran who's over 3-2
strikeouts a fly to center you can put
the red sox in front
sharply into right field for a base hit
here comes rafael devers here's the
throw home and he is safe on his feet
and the red sox take the lead three to
two big hit big hit by duran two down on
the bottom of the ninth in a one-run
game
did he go
they appealed yes that is strike three
and the ball game is over
the red sox win it three to two
they have knocked off tampa bay tonight
at the drop auto vino locks it up as he
strikes out loud